[Music]
all right i wanted to pull up an article
that was probably going to piss off nick
dude i don't know why you guys always
say that and usually right when you say
that i'm i'm like immediately just you
just use been debunked
yesterday
um so
a tour de france rider boom
i hate those guys dude stay in your
[ __ ] lanes you know
i'm just kidding every step of this is
gonna hate it i support all cycles
what's next it wasn't even the tour de
france writer it was the fan who walked
in the middle who got in the way trying
to get [ __ ] on his cell phone
i hate those [ __ ]
i hate the [ __ ] that does that
[ __ ] and then you make one guy crash and
then 20 people crash yeah and don't try
to set records so this crash definitely
was a crash because this tour de france
rider ends up breaking his neck after
the collision
breaking his neck guy that got in the
way he needs to be executed yeah you
don't you don't bro it's like you see
the [ __ ] bike people come in tell you
he's good
how are you taking pictures this is the
worst thing go on the side would you
guys be mad if you broke your neck and
then your homie came visit you at the
hospital and played the busta rhymes
breaking next song
if it's the friend and then you're like
this
nod your head
if i couldn't like move to it yeah yeah
yeah
just moving your feet
beat your feet
break it
talk to me all right anyways um
yeah so a tour de france rider has been
forced to abandon the race after
suffering a broken neck following a
collision with a fan
the italian writer for team total
energies
remarkably managed to power through to
the end of the stage but has since
retired from the race due to the
injuries suffered during his crash wait
so he continued the course with a broken
neck what a [ __ ] g bro
holy [ __ ]
that's amazing yeah it is how do you do
that it's just not he's just dangling
i'm at the feet he's already oh because
he's italian
or what he feels a little different
italian
[Music]
hey i'm riding here come on the finish
line's only five meters away come on so
cycling fans are famous for their desire
to get close to the action but this
spectator overstepped the mark why do
cycling fans want to be like what do
they want to do because they show up to
go watch cycling that's the problem they
have low iqs already you know you would
think a sport that you you think a sport
you love so much you would have some
kind of respect for it
to be honest i think all fans and their
respective sports have low iq they kind
of suck
even mma right they're like screaming
dumb [ __ ] into the [ __ ] crowd or like
uh like like you have all those uh memes
of like kevin durant having to like tell
a fan like shut up because he's telling
kevin i hope your kids die in a car
crash yeah yeah yeah they're just saying
crazy what's that famous basketball game
where the dude started fighting the
people in the ground
i love rhonda what was that the palace
was that the palace malice at the palace
and that happened because of fans
yelling some [ __ ]
and throwing [ __ ] they were actually
throwing [ __ ] and there was a time when
like ronnie tess was like [ __ ] it so he
lies down on the announcement table but
then somebody chucks another like
[ __ ] can of beer or whatever so then
he gets back up and then another a fan
comes down to the court and fans aren't
even supposed to be on the court and
like kind of squares that uh squares up
on it so ron just punches him yeah it's
amazing to see like keyboard warriors in
real life right makes me sorry and then
you see a six nine probably like 260
dude just like hop over these [ __ ]
like human-sized chairs and just go like
he's here and he goes wow someone like
that's five [ __ ] bleachers and you're
and you just
and you're like that's what you get
[ __ ] nothing gets my dick harder
than that
oh so the spectator was thrown to the
ground by the crash um and the biker
obviously was chucked off his bike uh
and into another rider who was also
taken out in the crash dude those
wipeouts are really bad man yeah they're
really like when they're funny when they
fly off their handlebars they really
they're really funny with the right
music i know
it's got to be the building beneath
america america
america
[ __ ] yeah
yeah anyways additional examination
revealed a fracture of a cervical
vertebrae requiring immobilization for a
few weeks so he's going to recover but
he's immobilized for weeks
um but
he's therefore forced to leave the tour
de france um they should have gone they
should have kept the guillotine in in
france dude they should have kept it and
they should have used it for shitty
cyclists fans that get in the [ __ ]
way it just hurts it just hurts so much
because for specifically for toyota fans
like these are people that trained and
gave their lives to do this thing is the
tour de france every year i think so it
is right or like oh so you can just do
it next year yeah
i don't even know but it's like [ __ ]
a thousand miles or two these guys train
so freaking hard to do the tour de
france like it's like there it's like
yeah it's considered the most
prestigious and most difficult bicycle
races what is this like one week long or
something it's an annual men's event
that's primarily held in france i hope
the guy that caused the crash got hurt
really bad too they usually [ __ ] yeah
probably didn't get hurt enough man so
in not poetic justice uh definitely
didn't get hurt enough but the other
rider who crashed into him the second
rider
also got really injured
uh the second rider involved in the
crash austrian alpechan phoenix rider
michael goggle was also forced abandoned
due to a broken collarbone and pelvis oh
my god so do these riders on twitter
friends do they have protective gear or
they just have the little he's got those
[ __ ] tights and [ __ ] yeah they've got
this thing not expecting to go into a
collision course with another human
being you know what i'm saying the
question that that begs now is how how
did the guy that they hit not get as
hurt as these trained athletes because
usually it's probably they're probably
super stiff on the thing the whole time
well also probably a guy getting hit is
just kind of like getting impact right
so any variable can happen there but
another person on a bike flying off the
bike is in like a physical propelling
like nature and they they're already
going at like maybe 30 40 miles an hour
science
so the speed that they're going and then
on top of the guy that broke his
collarbone in his pelvis you said he got
collided into right
yeah so he probably wouldn't even see it
happen yeah and then all of a sudden he
just [ __ ] wiped out you know such a
shame he can't really see those instant
airbag things these fools should wear
them yeah their helmet
that's really like hit the grounds like
this oh for a road is that a real thing
yeah yeah i don't think that they've
been like fully approved for consumers
and [ __ ] improve it right now but
it's for motorcycles right
it's for motorcyclists i think so but
maybe it's just electric bike yes
uh to answer your question the race is 3
500 kilometers [ __ ] that's like 17 miles
i think right 17 miles
i was like
obviously i don't know what kill a llama
that's like 3 000 miles probably or
maybe like two thousand miles apart
and these guys are going well like 50
miles per hour thousand miles they're
going fast depends on which part is
because this part happened unfortunately
on the cobblestone area of the race
which you [ __ ] fall in cobblestone
like there's no there's no give you know
what i mean well dude those guys wipe
out so [ __ ] yeah they wake up
if there was a fan with their [ __ ]
phone out in front of me and i was
[ __ ] racing i'm
on my way down i'm gonna grab the finger
[ __ ] try to bend it yeah that's why i
just like that sword let's grab their
hand yeah try to [ __ ] break that [ __ ]
they should give like the cyclists like
uh chain links and they could just hit
the [ __ ] yeah
joust the [ __ ] but i've seen
enough videos where like fans are
walking in the middle of the lane and
then one lady she like yeah she doesn't
even know that the cyclist is like
there at all you know there's some
people that really can't judge distance
and time and speed and they just like go
and wow
she stops in the middle gets hit and
she's knocked out immediately she's
stiff
and the guy flies off his [ __ ]
handlebars you know the the opening
stage of the 2021 race was marred by a
huge pileup started when a spectator
stepped into the road holding a sign
with her back to the race why isn't that
one on video yeah i think so imagine my
entire who is allowing these people oh
i'm sure it's so crazy it's such a long
like uh you know these [ __ ]
route right if they want to show up at
these guys work you should flip it on
them have [ __ ] lance armstrong show
up to their accounting firm and go
[Music]
[ __ ] just whack the fish
how do you like show up at your work
[ __ ] hit him with a bunch of
live strong bands
your [ __ ] is the monitor [ __ ] shaking
and [ __ ]
but also it's kind of crazy to watch um
bike because it goes it passed by so
quickly
and they're like hey
that's it that's yay
that's why that's why you're a [ __ ]
loser watch this [ __ ] at home dude yeah
watch and you can watch the whole trail
the game
you want to drive another 200 miles down
this way
this is the
2021 last year pileup uh incident check
out this one no way a little closer to
the 126 has they've gone under that
close this oh my god what happened what
has happened
right on the side of the road look at
this i don't know what happened there
maybe they clipped the cloud but
whatever has happened
they are in a right mess down there at
the moment now how many imagine that one
fan causing that
that is a massive crash bomber
jumbo fisma there was a fan with a sign
on the side apparently
and go down oh he might have clipped
that speck off the road oh he went off
the road
i think he went off the road the road
has got a nasty ridge on it there yeah
so it wasn't now the question is
watching it real life on that massive
it's not even a real sport it's fine
and they're all on epo anyway yeah yeah
you know they have to be though to be
competitive what's epo it's a
performance enhancement
gives you more red blood lance armstrong
thingy that he got popped for yeah but
that like apparently like they had to go
all the way down in like the top 20.
they all had it they all they were all
doing it they all retro tested they all
had it yeah isn't that the controversy
behind um
bruce jenner and his just like steroid
use and then like
and then in like after now like he um he
now has an imbalance of like
testosterone or something like that and
now now that's why he's like more
feminine and he had steroid usage they
confirmed it that's one of the theories
that was after he killed that woman on
pch that's when
when he crashed into her because there
was a car accident you rear-ended
somebody and then she flew into the
opposite lane and got killed but that at
that point he was already a woman
apparently there's something about bruce
jenner admitting to using peds in a 1988
interview
but i don't even know what the [ __ ] peds
are dogs i ain't no [ __ ] scientists i
don't know [ __ ] but i'm just like that's
just that's just wild putting all those
things in your system
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you